so I just want another fellow sort of
geek engineer geek
how would you weigh in on this because I
just told you how I did well I think I
was taking opposing views of yours I
think it's very responsibility to not
run faster than the ball I mean in there
maybe I went backwards but um I think it
needs to go backwards and everybody's
very much how else are we supposed to
enforce it oh let me just tell you this
Cameron oh that's a good answer
you just became my favorite Patriot ever
[Laughter]
is this calmly since it needs to go
backwards in everybody everybody's right
that's a great answer
I got no rebuttal to that Wow Cameron
you've done a good you've done something
interesting there